a persone o qua non si dice quando voi
vi ha sbagliato bella ragazza i minuti
che sono video io sono fra vj e oggi
vorrei togliermi un sassolino usassi
quelli grossi che quando gli spacchi dai
mattoni semplice allora spieghiamo
questa roba
nel modo più easy in modo che tutti
capiscano sito dedicato un video che è
un video star of ormai mi piace parlare
dei problemi quindi si dai facciamo
diventiamo uno di quindi quei di quei
posti dove ti siedi e facciamo sono
lorenzo 20 anni e faccio lo youtube ecco
parliamo di questo parliamo di un
argomento nuovo su youtube una cosa alle
prime primordiale mettiamola così forte
night è un gioco butter royale dove ti
butti in mezzo a spicchi la gente se sei
l'ultimo rimasto hai vinto questa allora
videogioco batterlo ial non so da dove
che nasce precisamente però diciamo che
hunger games ha contribuito un sacco a
questa cosa devi battere perché poi
tutti hunger games e figo quindi
facciamo sopravviviamo ultimi ai temi
quindi c'è stato il batterlo ial di
minecraft nel 2012 un sacco di tempo fa
fichissime lo gioca un sacco poi h1 z1
che la sto gioco che è la four nights
solo sei anni fa poi uscito the killing
anche quello strafigo bellissimo portato
sul canale poi player a non battere case
poi fort knight ok a me è sempre
piaciuto tantissimo il genere butter
royale c'è sempre
mi è sempre piaciuto faccio schifo a
giocare con altro discorso
però mi è sempre piaciuto provare a
vincere ogni tanto vinco anch'io quando
gli altri si addormentano sulla tastiera
mi è sempre piaciuto fino a un certo
punto quando ha smesso di piacermi
quando fortnight è esploso come gioco
cioè nel senso è diventato mainstream
adesso anche chi non ha mai toccato una
tastiera un joystick gioca fortner il
che non è un problema perché che cosa me
ne frega a me se un gioco esplode ben
venga perché solleva un po i videogiochi
nel mondo no figo
c'è un però questo però è un però molto
grande e visto che tanti ma tanti mi
chiedono di giocare a four nights e
quindi io mi vedo costretto a fare
questo video strano ultimamente sto
facendo video dove parlo di un sacco di
cose solo youtuber compì iscritti in
italia
e non faccio four nights mai o meglio
quasi mai loro fatto due tre volte da
quando ha aperto il canale lo facevo di
più quando non era ancora mainstream
perché ho smesso di farlo per un
semplice motivo perché la gente ha
iniziato a farmelo odiare
me l'hanno fatto odiare four nights
maledizione che è per me mi è sempre
piaciuto anche prima che ci fosse batte
royale perché fortemente non nasce col
butter royal montin anche lo sanno era
un altro gioco prima il battere gal è
una cosa in più
adesso vede quella cosa che potete
cliccare prima di andare sul batterio a
c un tasto strano quel quello lì ecco
quello era fortemente di prima
probabilmente quel tasto non so che cosa
esiste ancora fare ma non cambiamo
argomento perché quindi la gente ha
iniziato a farmi odiare forte night
allora voi lo sapete che io sono uno
youtuber che cerca di intrattenere
quindi io gioco ai videogames
principalmente per divertirmi non lo
faccio mai per competizione e c'è una
grandissima ma enorme differenza forse
molti di voi non non la capiscono perché
dicono a quello gioca ai videogiochi
quello e un gameplay era un gamer è un
no io non mi definiscono anche gamer in
realtà mi definiscono i giornali gamer
perché vedono che gioco quindi a un
gamer e neanche mi definisco kaymer io
definisco più intrattenitore li utilizzo
il gioco come mezzo per intrattenere
cioè in base alle cose che succedono nel
gioco io ho delle reaction e intrattengo
in questo modo thomas ad esempio un
gamer perché giochi e videogiochi e lo
fa in modo competitivo come ho sempre
giocato a tutti i giochi per divertirmi
quindi quelli dove si spara coni dove si
costruisce quelli dove si nuota anche
fortunate io l'ho sempre giocato per
divertirmi ma in competizione lo faccio
per divertirmi quindi quando il gioco a
fornte se vinco bella lì ho vinto che
figata
se non vinco non importa perché comunque
io nel video c'è con intrattenere ad
esempio uno dei video di formenti che mi
ha dato di più era questo è totalmente
invisibile non si muova
va bene resta quindi io anche su forte
ma che ormai è un gioco diventato
competitivi competitivissimo cerco di
intrattenere perché mi piace divertire e
mi piace divertirmi questa cosa io
purtroppo non la posso più fare perché
quando da quando four nights è esploso
un sacco di gente si aspetta credo da me
della competitività cosa che a me non
frega un c a me non importa di vincere
le partite di essere bravo io gioco
tanti giochi sul canale non mi concentro
su un gioco solo cerco importanti di
sempre più contenuti possibili quindi
non posso fermarmi sul gioco solo magari
ci sono i giochi che faccio di più
rocket league of the forest centra però
non bacio il mio canale su un gioco
tutti gli spettatori di fornita al
giorno d'oggi cercano la competitività
anche su youtube cioè tu seguino
youtuber perché vuoi vederlo vincere
cioè se arrivi secondo 6 la melma questi
sono family friendly ed è proprio per
questo motivo che la gente ha iniziato a
farmelo odiare perché ogni volta ogni
volta che io gioco a fort knight la
gente mi rompe le balle della serie è ma
non si spara così è ma il pompa lo devi
lasciare per terra se trovi un fucile
d'assalto cose del genere ma che tu vuoi
io gioco come voglio se voglio giocare
per divertirmi e fare lo scarso
chissenefrega cioè non è quello se vuoi
cercare youtuber competitivi che giocano
a forth and in modo competitivo vai da
altre persone
ciccio kaymer vai da faida power che
fanno questo in modo competitivo non da
me io non faccio quello e non trova
soddisfazione non mi diverto se mi
concentro troppo io gioco per divertirmi
e basta non che chi gioca competitivo
non si diverte ma non sono io quel tipo
di persona siamo tutti diversi
quindi basta chiedermi forno io giocava
fornite a tantissimi altri giochi batte
royale prima di fornai prima ancora che
si ragazzini conoscessero il mondo dei
videogiochi ci giocavo già prima quando
questi mi dicono e non si gioca così io
già ci giocavo da fornet prima ancora
che loro lo conoscessero ma non l'ho mai
fatto in modo competitivo quindi quando
io portavo all'inizio fornet sul mio
canale ci divertiamo un sacco era
fighissimo perché poi la gente mi
chiedeva dai porta altri video era
sempre figo perché non c'erano sti
ragazzini che rompevano le palle
su come devi giocare poi quando iniziate
a diventare popolare secondo subentrare
queste questi qui queste persone questi
giocatori di fort knight che ogni 3x2 ti
devono scrivere non si fa così emma sei
scarso e a destra a sinistra e io ci
giocavo già prima prima non c'era un
rotture di palle poi esploso fornet da
quando esploso ci sono le rotture di
palle anche se lo giocavo già prima
quindi bassa a una certa ho detto basta
non mi importa se portare forte mi fa
fare più views perché molti mi hanno
iniziato a scrivere ma c'è questo
problema su youtube delle views
e allora perché non porti four nights
che chi fa forte fa le views è vero che
chi fa four nights fa le views e quindi
se io portassi for tonight farei tipo il
30 40 per cento in più delle views ma
non lo farò mai
c'è mimì è più forte di me quando lo
apro so già che la gente mica che rai
come gioco quindi no preferisco
veramente divertirmi su altre cose che
portare un gioco che ormai è stata
giocata da tutti dove tutti si credono
dio in terra
e se lo porti devi fare tutto alla
perfezione sono l'agente di rompere
allora non lo faccio più perché non
trova soddisfazione non mi diverto nel
farlo e lo sapete che io prima di tutto
nei miei video vi devo divertire è vero
che youtube è un lavoro quindi è vero
che io devo fare le visualizzazioni
perché porto la pagnotta a casa ma è
anche vero che per me youtube in primis
è un hobby e da queste cose anche lo
dovreste capire che io non porto i
contenuti solo perché me lo chiede la
gente ma porto ciò che mi diverte punto
tranne che mario quello è un fa schifo a
prescindere quindi ragazzi parte gli
scherzi spero abbiate capito il perché
io non porto four nights se succede
succede una volta proprio ogni tanto ma
proprio quelle volte sporadiche e quando
succede non guardo i commenti perché
l'avete capito però il di base io non
porterò mai forner se volete forte
andate su altri canali che poi comunque
fanno lo fanno tutti quindi anche forse
meglio che non lo faccia io che palle
cioè non ci dividiamo un po le cose non
ha senso che io vada in un campo che già
super giocato per quanto mi possa
portare views e chissenefrega quindi se
volete farne andate ad altra gente io
faccio altri contenuti magari anche
batte royal scavi da ma non fornet
quindi questo è il discorso
spero che vi sia piaciuto
datemi se oggi non ho fatto un gameplay
ma volevo parlarvi di questa cosa perché
negli ultimi mesi mi erano arrivate un
sacco di domande sul perché non porti
four nights continuano ad arrivarmi
ancora adesso e penso che continueranno
ancora nonostante sto video perché
purtroppo non è che li guardano tutti i
video poi aggiungiamoci il problema
dell'algoritmo ciao però va beh speriamo
che sia così è stato chiaro spero vi sia
piaciuto
domani ci vediamo con un altro video
sicuramente non sarà fornita detto
questo per concludere il discorso io non
ho niente contro poi se parliamo ai
ragazzini ragazzini leggono un tipo uefa
vigeo di a forme cancro schifo
quindi facciamo una conclusione fatta
bene è dettata in modo elementare anche
per i ragazzini io non odio forni
fornite un gioco bello è bello e
luccicante sbrilli e colorato e
bellissimo però io non lo fa non lo
faccio perché la gente mi ha rotto
quella roba lì che fa rima però non è
claudio è bello quindi gioca c'è
divertiti che è un bel passatempo
appunto si sa ma io che ho chiuso i
commenti di questa faccenda sembra vi
sia piaciuto poi si vede vincitore c'è
un momento è un mi piace anche la pagina
di vista granché come hai vissuto nella
descrizione se non siete per i siti
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo come sempre
ad un prossimo video beh ragazzi